for only a few weeks away from the
launch of the Nintendo switch and you
might be wondering what else you'll be
able to play other than Lynx latest
adventure
well Nintendo has announced that a free
demo for splatoon 2 will be hitting the
switch shortly after launch the free
splatoon 2 global test fire event will
be available for three days from March
24 to 26 but only during designated
one-hour windows and here they are March
24 12 to 1250 9:00 p.m. and 8:00 to 8:50
9 p.m. March 25th for 2 4:59 a.m. 12 to
1250 9 p.m. and 8:00 to 8:50 9 p.m. and
March 26 from 4:00 to 459 a.m. all dates
are in Pacific time there will be four
different main weapons available in the
demo including the new splat Julie's as
well as remixed versions of the splat
roller and splat charger splatoon 2
launches for Nintendo switch sometime in
summer 2017 for all the up-to-date info
on splatoon 2 and the Nintendo switch be
sure to LIKE and subscribe and don't
switch away from GameSpot I'm so sorry
about that Joe